to do yeah I'd like to even go a little
simpler than that uh you know Google
Calendar and tungle knows where I'm
going to be for each appointment so like
right now it knows I'm here because I
put in Tong at my house or or I can even
put an address in it right if I'm going
to be I'm in palal this afternoon at the
tech runch s this evening in afternoon
and so why would it let somebody from
San Francisco put anything on my
calendar because I'm going to be between
halfman Bay and Pa walto and it knows
that and there's a couple hours I'm not
going to go to San Francisco in that
couple hours you know so if if you guys
can figure out an algorithm and say hey
that's not really an appropriate time
because you're in selo or some other
place in the world and he's going to be
in paloalto in San Francisco or in in
halfman Bay in PA Alto and we know that
he's going to be between those two
places and you want to go somewhere else
doesn't work find another day that you
know he's going be cuz there's other
days where I am in San Francisco and it
would be like oh it's only 15minute
drive from that other appointment and
and I I often you know schedule things
and then look at and go I was really
stupid for accepting that and and uh
then I have to delete it or you know
renegotiate like I can't really do it on
that day I have to move you to this
other day because I'm going to be in San
Francisco this other day and then he's
like oh I'm out of the country that day
you know it's like oh man now we have to
get back into the renegotiation phase
and it's almost easier to go on the
phone and say okay just call me up right
yeah the other thing and I have a weird
job so it's it's gonna be hard to
translate this to other people but I go
around the world and interview people
right and I find I can do two maybe
three interviews if I'm doing three
every day right I'm burned out right I
it's too much so the way I solve that is
to just cut down the number of hours
that I'm available but that's stupid
because I sometimes that second
interview can only happen at night so
now I have to you know somebody's like
your Calendar's booked for the next
three weeks because I blocked it all off
you know and now how do I get on there
for tomorrow night you know because I
have something like Saturday night I'm
actually interviewing somebody because
they have an extraordinary iPad app
coming out and it's like okay I want to
see this I don't want to wait right
right five months for to see it and so I
stick them in there but I had to do that
manually off the tongo me grid right
it'd be nice to say you know is this an
interview or is this a sushi dinner you
these are the typ these are the types of
meetings that I'm willing to break the
rules for right well that's one thing
but other thing is hey I've already
filled up my two two interviews for the
day I don't want to I don't I can't do
anymore but I want to keep the day open
for other kinds of things you know you
know this kind of stuff right I mean
this isn't really an interview so you
could send people to one page if it's
interviews and another page P for social
stuff but but then you know if if it
gets booked there it's no longer there
for people to be able to pick that makes
sense different types of lights or
profiles or right and or I can block out
yeah or even I can block out you know
and for PR people I can block out a
certain kind of slot and for my wife she
gets different right it's uh yeah that
makes sense cuz she she's allowed to
book me but it's it's hard to do that
simply and the iPad teach you know
Apple's teaching us if you have too many
features and you put too much crap on on
the counter and you lose it you lose you
know any beauty that you're going to
have that makes sense and then
everybody's like I'm not going to use
that it's too complicated and so that's
a an interesting challenge you guys
faced how do we fit more features that
solve these weird use cases but keep it
simple and intuitive and yeah how do you
how do you make so that everybody goes
man that's cool you know they'll
there'll be a company here and a company
here and they'll take the 45 minutes in
between I'm like I got to travel between
here and here you know so then I had to
start blocking things out and and that
but it
also I like uh thinking about you know
the the pacing of a week a day and and
if I'm letting other people be in
control of my calendar I can't do that
and they'll take every available hour
because they want my attention and so I
got to remember oh I need to exercise I
need to spend time with the family and
I'm not doing enough of that are you
scheduling that stuff just out of
curiosity I well I I make it so that
tungle can't take more than a couple
hours a day so people only can have a
few hours
um uh and yeah I'm blocking morning time
out I don't do I don't do anything the
morning usually um but yeah I Even Stu
you guys in a 10 which which I
appreciate I usually don't but that's
why I sort of keep like 411 open one so
I can sleep and and do some exercise and
stuff like that so you to sleep you roll
over